so if you're looking for a
family-friendly halloween event
we have you covered alex yes we do the
city of henderson is hosting a
drive-through haunted experience
and bianca holman is there live right
now to tell us more
hello bianca hey alex hey john so
all my parents i know you've taken the
kids out to the pumpkin patch you've
carved the pumpkins
you've done all of that but now the kids
they want to dress up and they want to
have fun they still want to trick or
treat
and of course we are in the city of
henderson where they have an event where
the kids can get dressed up you can
still be socially distant
and to tell us more about it i'm joined
by chuck with the city of henderson so
tell me what do you all have going on
this year so we have the haunted in the
desert it's a
drive-through haunted house it's a great
opportunity to bring the kids out
enjoy some holiday fun some halloween
activities while staying in your vehicle
staying in that socially safe bubble
that
you need to stay in yeah and i
understand of course it's kind of quiet
out here right now but
y'all are going to have some extra
things going on later on tonight
we will we have a we have a couple
spiders that are
supposed to be working as you can see
they're not working right
now yeah and then we have some actors
that will be out here uh
adding a little bit more of a spook
factor yeah but not too scary because of
course you know this is for the kids too
we don't want them to have nightmares
so we're trying to keep it very family
friendly they'll be dressed
similar to skeletons yeah as you can see
we're kind of in a theme of
a western type theme so it'll be kind of
a western type
fun fun fun and also of course they're
not going to leave empty-handed
tell me is this free it's parents you
know they're looking to save this this
holiday season they got to save up for
christmas and stuff so
tell us does it cost anything and will
kids be able to get some candy in the
meantime
so it is a free event we have 500 bags
of candy that will be given out to
any of the kids that are two to 12 years
old okay great
anyone in the vehicle that's two to
twelve years old will get a bag of candy
fun fun parents don't try to steal your
kids candy now okay don't try to hide it
from them it's for the kids
well wonderful so this starts tonight
six pm to nine right
yes it's tonight six six to nine pm
and then it'll we'll do it again
tomorrow and again on halloween wow
three days and of course again we're
going to tweet out this information
it'll be on our facebook page also
so again mark your calendar you can
start having that halloween fun
tonight dress the kids up and come on
out here to the city of henderson send
it back to you guys in the studio
yeah that looks fun bianca bianca how
did you know
that we steal our kids candy how did you
know that
yeah that's what my parents did
that's what my parents did chad is
shaking his head
he's stealing his little girl's candy
too that's what it's all about it's like
kids what did you get
out of the way let's just count your
candy and see
my brother my brother used to hide his
bags because he would know
i would come and look right i would take
the stuff he didn't like though you know
like the dot
oh i see oh you were doing him a favor
yeah yeah okay thank you
stuff it in the stuff the candy deep in
the closet then a month or so later oh
wow i forgot about all these snickers
bars
shocker that looks like a lot of fun
down uh down near the gallery mall down
there in henderson so we'll check back
in with
a very haunted bianca holmen uh in a
little while longer in the morning